they don't forgive because there's
nothing to forgive because I'm stuck and
I'm stuck in the oppressor group if I'm
stuck in the oppressor group and there's
no escaping it there can be no
forgiveness if there's no repentance
right like isn't that how it works so
then I'm just perpetually a sinner and
I'm just gonna continue to perpetuate
the oppressor group and there's nothing
that I could do it's almost an
impossible place to put yourself because
you're trying to hold something you're
trying to be open you're trying to
retain ideas and and also not put people
down it's tough what do you make of this
idea so you hit on that that critical
theory whatever you cultural Marxism
whatever you want to call this thing
that it's religious in nature one of the
one of the facets that I'm constantly
amazed by is there's no forgiveness in
this thing that basically if you're
white or you're cisgendered or you're
Christian or whatever you're privileged
and thus bad and that really you just
have to pay penance your whole life you
have to live on your knees your whole
life where most religions have some
level of forgiveness right you can
actually atone for your sins and
hopefully be a better person on the
other side this thing doesn't have that
this thing has oh well live like a slave
forever in effect but yeah hundred
percent so so in in critical theory
you're sort of guilty you know before
proven innocent
so everybody's guilty and as James
Lindsay he has observed and in his
findings all of the critical theorists
believe essentially that if you won't
even even you know for example I want to
be somebody accused me of problematic a
yesterday
but that's the whole point the whole
point is that I can never be truly an
ally
my ally ship is always going to be
problematic there's you know like so
there's no there's no there's no end to
it it just continues to be what it is so
yeah they they they don't forgive
because there's nothing to forgive
because I'm stuck and I'm stuck in the
oppressor group if I'm stuck in the
oppressor group and there's no escaping
it there can be no forgiveness if
there's no repentance right like isn't
that how it works
so then I'm just perpetually a sinner
and I'm just gonna continue to
perpetuate the oppressor group and
there's nothing that I can do yeah so
that's why of course cancel culture is
actually the logical conclusion of
critical theory right it's the logical
conclusion that to be consistent
logically they have to be consistent in
their cancel culture because they have
to get rid of the oppressor class I hate
to tell you I think it's beheading this
is the logical conclusion cancel course
just cancel culture is just a stop on
the way but we could sort of leave that
just for you personally dealing with
this the idea that everything's become
political and in many ways I think
people used to go to have religious
experiences regardless of the religion
they would go there to escape politics
that that religion sort of offered them
that you know that separation from the
real world to to think of something
timeless something like that to see it
all seep in just for you as a leader of
a community how's that been on you
yeah so so so one of the things that I
do in my role is I travel to a number of
churches I don't I'm like I'm not the
lead pastor in a community but I go to
all of the different communities and I
speak at the number of churches and so
what is it what is it like
well yeah people are people don't get
church is supposed to be a place where
they like hear about the love of God for
them and they hear about the sacrifice
that you know it and then they remember
the Lord's passion etc and so it's kind
of become in some circles in some
churches the gospel has totally become
about current events and I think that
that's definitely problematic
you know it definitely become
problematic where where in Christianity
we teach essentially that everybody's a
priest in fact the Protestant
Reformation happened because one of you
know Martin Luther's 95 problems with
the Catholic Church was that you had to
have a priest to connect with God and
the New Testament is replete with
scriptures about the priesthood of the
believer and so what this necessarily
means for Protestants like me is that
every believer is supposedly coming to
church to be a priest as what you
literally do is you come to and when
priests do they Minister the Lord and
they minister to others but like when
you come to church and it's a lesson on
critical theory you know and there's
like there's no escape I think that
people aren't able to do their job as a
Christian I think that that it's really
tough to glorify God and worship God
what it's like you're in a perpetual
classroom and there's just down there's
confusion and and I think that one of my
biggest frustrations for me is that I
don't think that a lot of church leaders
have their pulse on this epistemological
issue so it's just it's washing it like
pastors are good people and they love
people and so from that good place of
going I love people they're probably
going we need to talk about this because
this is a real this is this is this is
where the rubber hits the road but
problematically if you're not even have
your pulse on culture and understand and
the undercurrents epistemologically you
know you're creating a lot of confusion
for people so that's absolutely what's
happening
do you think certain religious
denominations and certain sex with in
religions are just better at keeping
some of this stuff at bay so it seems to
me it's not perfect but like something
like Orthodox Jews let's say have really
kept this at bay in a way that
conservative or reformed Jews haven't
been able to or evangelicals I think
have done a pretty good job at keeping
it at bay do you think that there are
like certain strengths and weaknesses
from a Protestant perspective or or
another denomination perspective that
makes certain worldviews a little more
able to stand up to these things
absolutely so it's a focus it's a focus
on on their purpose
like why does or why do Orthodox Jews
exist right like they know why and he
mean look right down sometimes to the
way that they dress like they're in this
world but they're not on this world sort
of as Jesus said and so I think that
that they do a really great job you know
of like focusing on their community and
focusing on the reasons why they exist
so there's a there's definitely a
balance to be sure we'll see when I look
at Jesus and that's once again this is
an epistemological issue but when I look
at Jesus I don't look at somebody who is
necessarily engaged the politics of his
day I think that you know Jesus said My
Kingdom is not of this world and so he
had a little bit of but I'm in the world
but I'm not of it does that mean that we
don't engage in issues of justice no
doesn't mean that we don't I think that
marching with Martin Luther King was the
right thing to do during the civil
rights and and
you know I think that defeating Hitler
was probably a good thing to do you know
like so there's there's that I think
that the church doesn't run from things
but it's it's finding its sifting
through the things that we should engage
it how you engage and the threshold of
that and it's a conversation that we're
having right now and uh yeah
evangelicals probably have done a really
great job because evangelicals are a bit
more heady Pennock offices are probably
a bit more we lean a bit more
experiential and so I'm uh that's you
know I I wish that Pentecostals you know
we're a bit more like evangelicals and
in that day they sifted they had their
you know like albert Mohler you know he
he's the the president of the Southern
Baptist Convention and he set out he
sent out a letter on critical theory to
all of the pastors and hey guys this is
what's happening like but Pentecostalism
is a bit of the Wild West and
Christianity I don't know if he knew
this but we've only been around for a
hundred twenty years and we there's 750
million of us and were the
fastest-growing version of Christianity
in the world like we're going to eclipse
we're going to eclipse Catholicism in 50
years so so hard brand of Christianity
in terms of filling stadiums and people
singing our songs and all the stuff it's
a it's it's a big place and it's like it
is the battleground for Christian
expression and that finding that
threshold of where politics are what
Christianity is going to look like etc
so Pentecostals don't we don't have we
don't have like a grand Pumbaa like an
albert Mohler or like a Jerry vowel or
whatever who
kind of dictates to us or will tell us
hey guys this is what's coming
independent so because of that because
the nature of that and because we're so
experiential and because we're so kind
of up on the culture
it's a mess right now but nobody knows
what to believe but we know that people
are hurting and so we're gonna run
towards people because we're
experiential people are having these
experiences so we're gonna love them but
that the rational part of our compassion
seems to be a bit missing and we're
unawares to what is really inside this
Trojan horse if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell